bom dia
compartilhar um pouquinho com vocês hoje
é da minha trajetória
falando um pouquinho de crowdfunding meu
primeiro contato com o call of fame foi
em 2006 2007 quando a palavra quando foi
nem existe ainda morava com essas
começou eu tempo passa né
essas figuras maravilhosas estão aqui do
meu lado nessa foto são os quatro
momentos enquanto fazia um dia lá em
berkeley e essa daqui a loirinha de
olhos brilhantes se chama play e ela é a
fundadora do jingle uma das maiores
plataformas de cloud fã do mundo ea
primeira lembro da gente discutindo a
idéia de um jingle da nossa cozinha
eu olhava pra eles assim ela mas os
cofundadores eu olhava pra ir lá em casa
sou muito doida mas essa idéia incrível
e foi acompanhando é basta basta
trajetória deles ao longo do tempo né
e aí adiantando um pouquinho pra hoje
foi de hoje é já tá girando em torno de
5 bilhões de dólares eo número de 2013
esse ano devem deve crescer bastante eo
próximo de 10 bilhões de dólares de de
transações nem de viabilização de
projetos e ver qual defendem em todas as
modalidades e se prevê que em 2025 serão
90 bilhões de dólares investidos é e
transacionado devia crowdfunding algo
mais as relações entre os dois maiores
players do mundo hoje do que está
atraído de gogo o que está já bateu em
um bilhão de dólares na plataforma é e
do google tem crescimento de 1000% em
dois anos já captou de de investidores
50 milhões de dólares e há pouco tempo
eles fizeram um case muito interessante
foi o primeiro bebê claudia andrade do
mundo
quando falo em é uma palavra que começou
a ser desmembrado em algumas modalidades
né
eu tenho um programa de doação como
forma de recompensa onde ainda assim é
uma é uma espécie de doação ea pessoa
que contribuiu recebe uma recompensa é o
modelo mais difundido é existe qualquer
plano de empréstimo onde o dinheiro de
fato é retornado é pago de volta pra
quem contribui com alguma alguma
remuneração quem tenho o código de
participação na gm chama de eco de
crowdfunding e que é onde estamos
trabalhando aqui no brasil é hoje e têm
modelos híbridos né que por exemplo onde
não participação com recompensa
vamos pedir a conta própria podem é ele
basicamente o mesmo propósito do quadro
fã de tradicional né e falar de
tradicional caldo planejar é uma coisa
meio esquisita porque é uma posição tão
nova vida tradicional mas enfim a
democratização do capital já é sua
capital é democratizar o acesso a
capital é de fato o grande propósito é
do crowdfunding
e tanto é que ficar falando enquanto o
plano de recompensas ou qualquer outro
explicou falando em usar o poder do
coletivo para a viabilização de projetos
nem tão poucos vou com as coisas
pequenas quantias de muitas pessoas dá o
poder do coletivo que de fato direciona
é hoje essa indústria
mas existem algumas diferenças nos
elementos entre o profano eo próprio fã
de recompensa
basicamente no qual o plano de
recompensas e tem projetos que pedem
doações e e que contribua recebe
recompensas não é continuar falando em
são empresas que pede investimento é
recebem e em contrapartida a
participação acionária de fato
e aí entra um elemento importante é do
crowdfunding que a reciprocidade né
reciprocidade é um conceito fundamental
dentro dessa relação e na verdade e
fundamental dentro de qualquer relação e
é isso que a gente acredita é as
tradições antigas de muitos povos
inclusive é tratam reciprocidade como a
base do equilíbrio das relações seja
sejam elas quais forem e de que natureza
forem desde a natureza de relações entre
pessoas
a relação de pessoas com a natureza a
relação das pessoas com o seu trabalho e
assim por diante
isso aqui é um caso interessante de um
índice acompanharam esse caso da óculos
que foi é ela captou em torno de dois
milhões e meio pelo que está há alguns
anos depois revendida para o facebook
por 2 bilhões ea pergunta que se colocou
a polêmica que cria que se criou foi que
de fato não se você é apoiar um projeto
no kickstarter que foi vendido por 2
bilhões de dólares
você merece você merecia ficar rico você
merece carro ou não
não existe uma resposta para isso mas
existe uma bela de uma discussão sobre
isso né então a reciprocidade
nesse caso é a seguinte cada pessoa
contribuir para óculos ganhava um óculos
ótimo estabelecido a reciprocidade mas
ela pode se desequilibrar
à medida que essa empresa é vendida por
2 bilhões de dólares tem um é um super
ganho de capital esse ganho de capital
que continua concentrado na mão de
alguém então na verdade está fazendo é
você tá trazendo usando o poder do
coletivo e direcionou para uma pessoa só
só aquela pessoa só que a entidade é que
vai usufruir de todos os benefícios
no final das contas então o que eu
acredito é que o episódio fama e traz
uma reciprocidade muito mais fortes na
relação de quem contribui com os
projetos com as empresas no brasil assim
como outros lugares do mundo nos
ecossistemas empreendedorismo existe um
plano de eficiência de um lado
empreendedores que têm dificuldades em
se financiar
a dificuldade de acessar investidores de
o momento de estabelecer uma primeira
conversa de entender que conversa é essa
que tem que ser estabelecida com os
investidores e se preparar para essa
conversa tem é processo muito
burocrático sé os sistemas de apoio do
governo são super morosos e dolorosas
vezes e por outro lado os investidores
eles têm é também dificuldade de
encontrar bons projetos
eles têm dificuldade de custa muito você
atrás do projeto é avaliar uma empresa
pequena tem o mesmo custo mesmo trabalho
que você vai a uma empresa grande né
então começa falando de investidores
deste mercado investimento anjo
investimento pequeno investimento de
alguns milhares de reais ou sem algumas
centenas milhares de reais
esse é um trabalho muito custoso é acho
que o ponto mais importante dessa
ineficiência que que essa nada pelo qual
de fanning é que muitas pessoas é que
poderiam estar contribuindo pra pra esse
ecossistema como investidores não estão
simplesmente pelo psi pelo simples fato
de que eles não têm uma quantidade de
recursos tão grande que torna se
possível que vocês terem uma idéia um
investidor anjo que é uma pessoa que
investe em empresas que estão começando
ele investe em torno de 50 mil reais em
cada empresa e ele não tivesse sozinho
ou raramente vai sozinho então ele veste
com mais quatro ou cinco investidores e
eles conseguem um ser humano por uma
empresa então entre 50 mil e trezentos
mil reais
bom se esse cara de r 50 mil cada
empresa ele precisa diversificar o risco
dele ele vai precisar de pelo menos 500
mil reais pra investir nessa categoria é
é de investimento hoje como isso tem que
ser pequena parte do portfólio de
investimento desse total
nesse caso é preciso na verdade
aproximadamente 5 milhões de reais em
caixa para ele poder ser um investidor
anjo tranquilamente sem colocar muito do
patrimônio dele é nesse ativo de um
ativo muito
risco né enquanto as pessoas têm de se
esse volume de dinheiro é no brasil para
poder participar
é desse tipo de operação é muito poucas
derrotas foram em faz é tornar este
mercado viável pra quem tem 100 mil
reais de reserva que pode colocar mil
reais em cinco empresas e formar uma
pequena carteira 2 mil reais e cinco
empresas uma carteira de dez mil reais é
então é hoje um problema muito grande
uma exclusão de muitos potenciais
investidores desse ecossistema por conta
do alto tíquete necessário para
investimento tiver com esse produto
também é é algo que dê para solucionar
isso
a partir dessa dessa identificação dessa
dessa ineficiência a gente começar a
trabalhar nesse novo paradigma né
um ponto de encontro entre
empreendedores e investidores uma
plataforma que usa o poder do coletivo
para a viabilização de projetos de
empresas com o propósito de por um lado
democratizar o acesso à capital por
parte dos empreendedores e por outro
lado também democratizar o acesso a
oportunidades de investimento é pelos
investidores e daí surgiu a maçã a nossa
empresa que é o meu sócio
acho que é uma coisa muito importante um
aprendizado muito importante desse
processo é a importância do propósito da
intenção
então você refletir muito sobre o
propósito do projeto que você está
conduzindo e da intenção que você está
trazendo pra esse projeto a partir de
que lugar dentro de você você está de
fato exercendo e trabalham naquele
projeto a força da nossa intenção é
torna tudo muito mais poderoso
hoje o pai por causa de todo mundo ele
já ajuda bastante bastante movimento em
torno de 400 milhões de reais de dólares
investidos com a previsão é de 700
milhões para 2014 em vários tipos de
empresa desde startup de tecnologia
mercado imobiliário é energias
renováveis e também negócios locais
no brasil a gente começou a rodar
bastante essa essa legislação do brasil
existe um espaço para o ft produção de
acontecer como em diferentes lugares do
mundo em que é preciso mudar a
legislação no brasil já existe um espaço
é que torna possível e viável é peter
crouch expandem basicamente pequenas e
micro e pequenas empresas é já podem
fazer esse tipo de captação é desde que
de fato ela comprou alguns alguns
requisitos né e por lá os investidores
que ele tem total noção é do que estão
fazendo de fato dado que é um é um
investimento de risco alto
a gente começou a trabalhar com essa
idéia é compartilhar essa ideia que
queria fazer isso no brasil a gente teve
esse realmente muitas pessoas assim
descrentes e a gente passou a importar
batinas gigantes e é isso que faz a
gente não consegue internalizar esse
feedback de forma é tranquilo harmoniosa
a gente já não estava mais aqui né então
acho que eu tenho um aprendizado
importante que ele possa confiar se
ancorar no propósito é e e entregar no
sentido de o que acontecer é bem vindo
mas também por victor com dois parceiros
muito importante é esse outro
aprendizado néné de fazer junto muito
mais fácil do que o que fazer sozinho a
gente conectou com claudio é uma
plataforma da europa de eco de
crowdfunding e estamos trazendo a
plataforma de e para o brasil
é ele conectou com o escritório de
advocacia muito muito grande e se muito
importante dentro do brasil com muita
experiência que trouxe pra gente sair
uma força bem grande
e esse foi o aprendizado não fazer com
pouco recurso é com ótimas parcerias
a gente vem trabalhando bastante no
nosso sócio e nessa operação
estamos preparando as primeiras empresas
para colocar o continuar o itinerário
colocar e fazer o lançamento da
plataforma efetivamente é de algumas
coisas que a gente que a gente olha
dentro de do que a gente vem estudando
néné muito trazendo otimismo é para essa
nossa atuação
muitos estudos já provam que acordo com
o grupo de provas onde funciona o qual
dispõe de forma geral também funciona
por uma série de aspectos primeiro lugar
a inteligência coletiva é ela de fato
funciona através dessa dinâmica estudos
já mostram que o coletivo escolhe
projetos melhor do que um especialista
não temos tudo foi feito com uma base de
de peças de teatro em que especialistas
escolheram as melhores peças de teatro
acho que deveriam ser financiadas e
essas peças foram na verdade e
financiada via própria van den
o resultado é que na maioria dos casos
essas opiniões elas batem mas em muitos
casos em casos em que é em muitos casos
em que os especialistas disseram não e o
coletivo financiou disse sim a peça foi
um grande sucesso então saber quem é a
natureza do coletivo ela sim funciona
pelo qual defende a criação de empregos
tão em pesquisa 87% dos projetos
empresas que foram viabilizados de
crowdfunding é de fato contrataram
pessoas democracia acesso então é o
quadro também promove a redução de de
alguns de alguns fiéis como por exemplo
o viés das mulheres empreendedoras e de
beleza muitos projectos liderados por
mulheres em termos de marketing vem
teremos também do negócio né
tem muitos benefícios e
ainda assim marketing na divulgação e
venda dos produtos é que foram objecto
de crowdfunding é retorno sobre
investimento e também avaliação é do
próprio negócio no mercado
tudo isso é um benefício que a gente já
vem vendo sendo estudados em pesquisas e
estudos e pesquisas sérias universidades
grande como é uma necessidade de perto
universidade da pensilvânia é dentre
outras
o que a gente espera é que a gente quer
trazer é como benefícios tanto para o
produtor quanto o vencedor são acesso
foco né
a assessoria o processo de captação mais
facilidade e agilidade é e acho que
basicamente assim mais importante que é
esse último ponto que a construção de
uma rede de aliados é pra essas empresas
então quando você consegue financiar sua
empresa via investidores de uma rede de
investidores você acaba de ganhar uma
rede de investidores que vai fazer de
tudo para que a sua empresa dê certo
então eles podem trazer para você novos
negócios para trazer pessoas para
trabalhar na sua equipe vão trazer
conhecimento né a gente vê vê caso lá
fora em que pessoas que de fato for são
investidoras de de empresas é que elas
participam inclusive borda das empresas
nem do dia a dia dessas empresas do
investidor que falou antes né acesso às
empresas é ajudar a diversificar o risco
e basicamente trazer mais investidores
para esse para esse mercado viabilizar
esse acesso é um grande amigo meu que é
o nasdaq de onde ele estava conversando
num café ele falou assim ah cara se
muito importante a gente pensar que está
a serviço de alguma coisa né você tenha
consciência disso não está sempre
independente do que esteja fazendo
alguma coisa você está perpetuando está
ajudando a perpetuar
e aí estava a refletir sobre esse
serviço não é popular o desafio
o nosso serviço é é a esperança de um
mundo que ele é mais democrática mais
transparente que oferece mais
oportunidades e mais acesso onde
propriedade renda são mais distribuídos
e onde a comunidade de fato a entidade
mais poderosa
obrigado